body count is an advantage for women
like if a woman has a higher body count
just because it takes time to get to a
place where you're trying so hard to act
like a man sexually you're just going
against nature and eventually it's going
to bite you in the butt and then it
makes you stroke like you struggle with
dopamine I think in a sense right if
you're a woman that gets instant
attention and you can't hold off on
getting in the bedroom and that's what a
lot of how to get a partner is dopamine
hacking because people like that reward
for the for the long effort if that
makes any sense if you're talking about
a woman being aloof you're talking about
a man being aloof and I think that
that's just getting into the dopamine
wiring that we're so fried from our
phones and things like that yeah yeah
sure yeah but I don't think that it's
bad if a guy has a high body count I
mean I wish I cared as a Christian I
wish I cared but I don't I don't care at
all